[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Wie sich es als Frau eines schwäbischen Ehemanns gehört,
mache ich heute Spätzle.
Okay, das war jetzt sehr
so rollenmäßig, nicht?
Alice Schwarzer braucht sich nicht bei mir melden.
Das war echt nicht frauenverachtend oder so gemeint.
Aber ich als Frau vom Murat,
von einem schwäbischen
Hausmann, Ehemann,
muss natürlich wissen, wie man Spätzle selber macht.
Jedenfalls sollte man,
egal, ob Mann oder Frau, ob jung oder alt,
wissen, wie man Spätzle selber macht.
Denn dafür braucht man wirklich nicht viele Zutaten.
Im Prinzip sind es hier diese vier oder drei sogar nur.
Ich habe hier einmal Mehl,
Eier,
Wasser
und Salz.
Und zwar könnt ihr für die Spätzle
einfach ein Spätzlemehl benutzen.
Das ist so ein griffiges Mehl.
Oder ihr nehmt einfach griffiges Mehl.
Das bedeutet einfach, dass es ein grobes Mehl ist.
Und es ist sehr quellfähig,
sodass einfach die Spätzle später schön bissfest bleiben
und eben nicht so weich werden.
Also man spürt es echt so zwischen den Fingern.
Es ist echt ein richtig schönes, angenehmes Mehl.
Und pro 100 Gramm Mehl verwende ich ein Ei.
Und ich nehme jetzt eine
– ja, ich nehme jetzt sechs Eier, also 600 Gramm Mehl.
Ich habe hier noch Mineralwasser,
also Sprudelwasser mit Kohlensäure,
und ein bisschen Salz.
Das ist das Grundrezept.
Und ich denke, später zeige ich euch
noch eine Version für Spinatspätzle oder Kräuterspätzle.
Denn ihr könnt das Grundrezept echt individuell abwandeln.
Und ihr braucht jetzt auch dafür
wirklich kein Rührgerät, keine Küchenmaschine,
sondern einfach so einen Backlöffel.
Gebt jetzt hier die Zutaten rein.
Das Salz noch dazu.
Ich werde heute auch zum allerersten Mal, muss ich sagen,
Spätzle selber schaben vom Holzbrett.
Ich werde einfach verschiedene Methoden ausprobieren.
Also das habe ich tatsächlich selbst auch noch nie gemacht.
Und jetzt hier Mineralwasser rein.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach so lange rühren,
bis der Teig Blasen wirft.
Also ihr können das mit einem Kochlöffel machen
oder mit den Knethaken eures Handrührgeräts.
Sarah sagte ganz liebevoll,
ich erinnere sie an ihre Oma.
Omas haben halt die besten Rezepte.
Und ich muss halt echt dazu sagen,
dass ich viele klassisch deutsche Rezepte
auch erst ganz spät kennengelernt habe,
weil ich eben nicht so eine klassische deutsche Oma hatte.
Ich hatte halt nur eine türkische Oma.
Und die andere Oma, von meinem Papa die Mama,
die ist schon verstorben, die habe ich nie kennengelernt.
Ja. Und die Mama von meiner Mama,
die hat halt nur türkisch gekocht.
Deswegen gab es nichts klassisch Deutsches,
außer ich war bei Freunden.
[Musik]
Wenn wir das nächste Mal unser Workout-Programm machen
von Pamela Reif, dann mache wir nicht
das 10-Minuten-Oberkörper-und-Abs-Workout,
sondern wir machen einfach Spätzle.
Wirkt genauso.
[Musik]
Also der Teig sieht super aus, schön elastisch.
Guckt einmal.
Perfekt!
Den decke ich jetzt ab,
lasse ihn ruhen
und kann schon mal meinen Topf mit Wasser ansetzen.
Jetzt nehmen wir an, ihr wollt keine normalen Spätzle machen,
sondern wirklich Basilikumspätzle oder Spinatspätzle,
irgendwas mit Kräutern und Gemüse.
Dann könnt ihr es einfach so machen:
Ihr nehmt das Wasser.
Ich habe jetzt hier Basilikum aus dem Garten.
Da hatten wir dieses Jahr auch echt viel.
Und je nachdem, wie doll es nach Basilikum schmecken soll,
nehmt ihr halt ein bisschen mehr oder weniger.
Bei Spinat genauso.
Da geht frischer Spinat oder auch gefrorener Spinat.
Aber den vorher gut ausdrücken.
Was ihr auch nehmen könnt, ist Rote Beete.
Oder ihr könnt einfach nur Kurkuma dazu geben.
Dann habt ihr eine tolle gelbe Farbe
und eben so auch einen tollen Geschmack.
Das jetzt kurz pürieren.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich das hier dazu.
Okay.
Es sieht gerade ein bisschen eklig aus.
Aber es riecht sehr gut.
Es riecht besser, als es gerade aussieht.
Und wie sich es für eine schwäbische Hausfrau gehört,
schön noch ausspülen,
nichts verschwenden.
Lieber Kevin, ich platziere jetzt
dein wundervolles Wiesentaler Mineralwasser.
Das kommt nämlich von hier, aus unserem Ort.
Ja.
Soll ich eben noch so einen Werbespot machen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte.
Nur mit dem Wiesentaler Mineralwasser
werden Spätzle wirklich fluffig.
[Musik]
Es sieht echt nicht so appetitlich aus.
Ich hoffe, das schmeckt.
Aber es riecht echt gut.
Ich glaube, so Spätzle mit so Tomaten...
Da haben wir ja fünf Millionen im Garten.
Oh, mit den getrockneten, mit den Mini-Cocktail,
das machen wir.
So. Wieder schön rühren, bis er Blasen wirft,
und dann einfach zur Seite stellen
abgedeckt.
Also ich bin jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen aufgeregt,
weil ich es echt auch zum ersten Mal
mit dem Brett mache.
Also ich weiß,
dass man es vorher mit Wasser nass machen muss.
Komm. Wir lernen es gleich zusammen, okay?
Das ist ein Spätzleschaber.
>> SARAH: Oma,
>> SALLY: Ich weiß aber auch, dass es die Oma
so mit Messer macht.
>> SARAH: es tut mir leid.
>> SALLY: Also, dass ich es nicht kann, Sarah,
ist nicht schlimm.
Denn ich hatte keine deutsche Oma,
die mir das beigebracht hat.
>> SARAH: Ich habe zwei deutsche Omas.
>> SALLY: Ja, und dann bist du noch
zusätzlich eine Schwäbin.
Das heißt, wenn ich es nicht kann, ist es echt nicht schlimm.
Mir verzeiht es jeder.
Aber, wenn du es nicht kannst
– du hast zwei schwäbische Omas.
>> SARAH: Der Druck ist nicht hoch.
>> SALLY: Der Druck ist nicht hoch.
>> SARAH: Die gucken das nicht.
>> SALLY: Aber die anderen Menschen.
>> SARAH: Die sagen das denen bestimmt.
Meine Mutter sagt es ihr. Ich weiß es.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Wie heißt deine Mama?
>> SARAH: Ute.
>> SALLY: Ute,
jetzt werden wir sehen, ob die Sarah das kann.
>> SARAH: Muss ich das auch so machen?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
>> SARAH: Nicht mal meine Mama macht das so.
>> SALLY: Ich muss echt fairerweise zugeben:
Ich habe so ein Video geguckt
von so einer schwäbischen Oma, die das macht,
und habe es mir echt einmal angeguckt.
>> SARAH: Von so einer schwäbischen Oma?
>> SALLY: Doch, der hat das vor zehn Jahren hochgeladen.
Und dann redet sie halt total schwäbisch.
Als ich habe jetzt hier den Topf mit Wasser.
Das kocht gleich.
Salz habe ich schon rein.
Und jetzt müsst ihr das so glatt streichen
mit Wasser immer.
Die hat das auch immer so reingetunkt,
muss ich echt dazu sagen.
Magst du eine Schürze?
>> SARAH: Hä? Die ist doch...
Ist die wirklich zu klein?
>> SALLY: Nö.
>> SARAH: Es ist doch okay eigentlich, oder?
>> SALLY: Das passt.
>> JOSH: Wespentaille.
>> SALLY: Bei so einer Taille
kann man auch die Kinderschürze tragen.
>> SARAH: Oh, darf ich Werbemodell sein
für deine Kinderschürzen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich hätte dir jetzt auch Murats noch.
>> SARAH: Boah, guck mal!
Was? So? Die ist Murats?
>> SALLY: Ich hätte dir jetzt auch Murats.
>> SARAH: Guck mal. Mein Knoten vom Gürtel
>> SALLY: Ah, stimmt.
>> SARAH: hat mir einen Bauch gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja, komm jetzt!
Ich habe doch schon PowerBoost.
Okay. Ich probiere es jetzt, okay?
Und dann muss man das so...
Oh!
>> SARAH: Gott!
>> SALLY: Ich bin so gespannt!
Das ist echt das erste Mal, dass ich das mache.
Und dann
– oh, aua!
Und du musst halt hitzeresistent an den Fingern sein.
>> SARAH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Und schön dünn.
Und dann immer wieder nach vorne.
>> SARAH: Crazy!
>> SALLY: Ich meine nicht, dass jetzt uns jemand bewertet.
>> SARAH: Nee.
>> SALLY: Aua!
>> SARAH: Wehe, es sagt jemand was!
>> SALLY: Ich hatte einfach
die kompletten Finger im heißen Wasser.
Das sind die Wienerle.
So sind sie auf die Idee kommen mit den Wienerle.
Aber guck mal, du musst echt,
wenn du es so streichst,
immer wieder Wasser,
schön glatt.
Also ich habe das bei der Oma gesehen.
Schön glatt.
Man könnte auch das Video von dieser Oma einfach verlinken.
Ihr Enkel hat das hochgeladen
und ich glaube, sie weiß es bis heute noch nicht.
Und das sah bei ihr so gut aus,
so richtig schnell, so professionell.
>> SARAH: Die macht das bestimmt jede Woche,
jeden Sonntag.
>> SALLY: Für alle Enkel.
>> SARAH: Ja, Spätzle für acht Personen.
>> SALLY: Aber ich glaube, wenn sich das so verteilt,
ist es nicht so gut.
Also eher so in der Mitte bleiben.
>> SARAH: Aber das sieht schon gut aus.
>> SALLY: Ja, oder?
>> SARAH: Könnte man da auch deine Teigkarte
dafür verwenden?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Du bist Produktplatziererin. Ich sehe das schon.
So.
>> SARAH: Und dein Schneidebrett?
Sturmis Schneidebrett?
>> SALLY: Sturmis Schneidebrett.
Aber das kann man halt nicht so halten.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Jetzt warte kurz.
Wir nehmen meine raus,
damit meine und deine...
>> JOSH: Geil!
>> SALLY: Ja. Entschuldigung?
Wir müssen sie schon auch optisch bewerten.
Okay. Also ich muss sagen,
sie sind nicht gleichmäßig.
>> SARAH: Oh, ich werde richtig gehatet. Ich weiß das.
>> SALLY: Sie sind nicht gleichmäßig.
Aber sie sind mit Liebe entstanden.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wie beim Kindermachen.
Das eine ist dicker, das andere ist dünner.
>> SARAH: Nicht gleichmäßig, aber alles aus Liebe.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ich glaube, wenn sie oben schwimmen, sind sie fertig.
Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, die sind schon lang fertig.
>> SARAH: Also ich mache da einfach so einen Bollen drauf?
>> SALLY: Ja.
So ein bisschen.
>> SARAH: Das kann jetzt was werden.
Ab jetzt könnt ihr das Video von der Oma einschalten.
>> SALLY: Spätzleschule Palik.
Palik und Ripplinger filmt.
Wie der stolze Papa.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: So, Palik.
Jetzt zeig mal, ob du es kannst.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt glatt streichen. Genau.
So. Jetzt mache ich es dir auch einfacher mit dem Wasser.
Hm.
Da tropft es dir gleich runter!
>> SARAH: Hey, ihr bringt...
Das ist so unfair!
Ihr bringt mich auch richtig durcheinander.
Wie soll ich mich da denn konzentrieren?
Geht das so?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ist es zu dick oder zu dünn?
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen zu dick noch.
Ja, so.
Und jetzt noch mal ins Wasser so zack, zack.
Genau. Und jetzt reinschaben, so richtig so abschneiden.
>> SARAH: Ach, ich muss bis da vor?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Und jetzt wieder dünner.
Dünner, dünner, dünner.
Sonst werden sie...
>> SARAH: Das ist so wabbelig.
>> SALLY: Ach, dann mach...
Egal. Dann mach...
>> SARAH: Dann mache ich dicke.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und das Brett ein bisschen weiter neigen.
Ja.
>> SARAH: Es tut mir leid. Das ist der Druck.
Normal
kann ich es besser.
>> SALLY: Also ich würde an dieser Stelle...
Wir zwei kennen ja noch einen Schwaben
außer Murat,
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: einen Urschwaben
und zwar den Sturmi.
Ich würde dich, Sturmi,
jetzt zum Handgemachte-Spätzle-Schaben nominieren.
>> SARAH: Du, Hammer!
Renn!
>> SALLY: Ab diesem Video hast du eine Woche Zeit,
dieses Video zu machen.
Ja.
Sonst
holt dich die schwäbische Geisteroma.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: So. Viel Spaß!
>> SARAH: Cut.
>> SALLY: Ich schicke ihm das Spätzlebrett.
Soll ich dir helfen?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja? >> SARAH: Bitte.
>> SALLY: So glätten.
Mein Kind, das ist...
>> SARAH: Guck mal. Warum ist das so?
Warum ist das da so...
>> SALLY: Das ist halt das Wasser.
Aber du schabst es ja dann weg.
Aber ich finde,
ganz ehrlich, dafür, dass wir das erste Mal gemacht haben,
>> SARAH: sehen die voll gut aus.
>> SALLY: finde ich, haben wir uns beide echt gut angestellt.
Komm.
>> SARAH: Also ich finde sie gut.
>> SALLY: Also die sind jetzt auch nicht so die dünnsten
Spätzle. Da habe ich jetzt ein...
>> SARAH: Und wir sind auch nicht die Dümmsten.
>> SALLY: Hier, guck.
Es sieht gut aus. Ich finde das...
>> SARAH: Darf man die probieren?
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich finde, das sieht...
Du musst die jetzt auch probieren.
Weil ich mache dich jetzt hier fertig.
Dann machen wir die gleich mit Linsen zusammen.
>> SARAH: Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde, du als waschechte Schwäbin
musst sie natürlich probieren.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Das mache ich.
>> SALLY: Nimm sie dir einfach raus.
Probier mal.
>> SARAH: Ach, ich soll jetzt schon probieren?
Ich dachte, mit Spätzle später.
>> SALLY: Ja, später noch mit Linsen.
Aber so...
>> SARAH: Ach, meine ich doch, mit Linsen.
>> SALLY: Aber so pur, finde ich, auch.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und das ist Sarahs Spätzle.
Aber ich kriege es gerade nicht an einem Stück raus.
>> SARAH: Ich mag so
>> SALLY: So.
>> SARAH: so ein bisschen klumpige Spätzle.
Das mag ich ganz gern.
>> SALLY: Aber ich bin finde
– guck mal, die restlichen sind echt gut.
>> SARAH: Die gibt es ja manchmal in Fertigpackungen.
>> SALLY: Das ist ein Spatz.
Ich finde es sehr gut.
>> SARAH: Es sind zwar viel weniger. Warum?
>> SALLY: Hattest du weniger Teig?
>> SARAH: Vielleicht.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde, ganz ehrlich,
du hast dich echt gut angestellt.
>> SARAH: Kann man jetzt so einen Applaus bringen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
[Applaus]
>> SALLY: Spätzlekönigin.
Also ich muss echt sagen, es hat Spaß gemacht.
Aber jetzt zeige ich euch noch eine andere Methode.
>> SARAH: Es hat Spaß gemacht.
>> SALLY: Falls ich die Spätzle
doch mit einer Spätzlepresse zubereite,
achte ich einfach darauf,
dass ich einen Topf nehme, der tief genug ist,
wo einfach viel Wasser drin ist.
Dann gebe ich ein bisschen heißes Wasser
über die Spätzlepresse,
fülle den Teig ein
und drücke die Spätzle direkt ins heiße Wasser.
Am besten dann unten noch ein bisschen verquirlen,
damit sich die Spätzle voneinander lösen
und dann weitergaren, bis sie fertig sind.
[Musik]
Also jetzt haben wir die langen Spätzle
und jetzt kommen noch Knöpfle.
Die machen wir jetzt hier so.
[Musik]
Also hier, muss man halt echt sagen, ist man schneller fertig.
Also ich habe jetzt die komplette Teilmenge hier drin.
Und man muss natürlich nicht so viel machen,
hat alles sofort auf einmal zubereitet.
Das war jetzt die Teigmenge mit vier Eiern
und 400 Gramm Mehl,
also so eine normale Haushaltsportion.
Und alle sind gleichzeitig fertig.
Man muss nicht warten.
Oh! Und die Farbe wird schöner.
Okay.
Und dann schwenken wir die in ein bisschen Butter.
Und dann sind die Spätzle fertig.
Und daraus könnt ihr
alles Mögliche zubereiten,
auch Käsespätzle machen
oder die zu irgendwas dazu servieren
oder so, wie wir es gleich machen werden.
Hier die grünen, die Basilikumspätzle,
werde ich einfach mit getrockneten Tomaten
ein bisschen anrichten.
Und dann hat man echt auch ein schnelles, leckeres Essen.
Ja. Und die anderen gibt es dann zu unseren Linsen dazu.
[Musik]
Also unsere selbst geschabten Spätzle,
die ich jetzt auch vermischt habe.
>> SARAH: Man sieht nicht, welche von wem sind.
>> SALLY: Nein.
Die können jetzt hier in Butter schön angebraten werden.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Dann kleben sie nicht mehr zusammen
und man hat natürlich mehr Geschmack.
>> SARAH: Ich habe die Hände gerade gewaschen.
>> SALLY: Ja, alles gut.
An dem Punkt sind wir schon lange vorbei.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was?
Joshs Blick hinter der Kamera so:
What?!
Die sehen jetzt auch gut aus, gell?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Du kannst gerne vielleicht eine Gabel holen.
Dann kann da so ein bisschen Tomaten rein
und dann ein bisschen Öl.
>> SARAH: Ich rühre es um.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber du kannst auch gern jetzt
– du kannst auch das nehmen.
>> SARAH: Danke.
>> SALLY: Und dann probieren wir jetzt, okay?
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also unsere Spätzle.
>> SARAH: Ich bin gespannt. Welche probieren wir als Erstes?
Unsere.
>> SALLY: Ich probiere die.
>> SARAH: Die wartet einfach nicht.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hast du es gehört?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Voll schön bissfest.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Ich muss so lachen.
Nee, die sind echt richtig gut.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich kann kaum glauben,
dass ich das geschafft habe
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: mit dir zusammen.
>> SALLY: Echt gut!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt die Basilikum.
Hm.
>> SARAH: Oh, das ist bestimmt auch
>> SALLY: Echt gut!
>> SARAH: mit dem Knoblauchöl und den Tomaten.
>> SALLY: Oh, und so fruchtig mit den Tomaten.
>> SARAH: Woah!
Das können wir auch einfach so essen.
>> SALLY: Ja, finde ich auch.
Also das ist wie
– und auch kalt.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wie so ein Salat.
>> SARAH: Voll!
>> SALLY: Voll gut!
Also...
>> SARAH: Ein bisschen Sauerampfer.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: O ja, ein bisschen Sauerampfer.
Und so Pinienkerne, geröstete.
>> SARAH: Woah! Ja, das würde auch.
>> SALLY: Und Rucola.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Und alles.
Wir haben unser Gemüse,
unseren Salat haben wir jetzt zusammen.
Also, falls euch dieses Video
mit den Spätzle gefallen hat, dann
schreibt es uns gerne drunter.
Vielleicht wollt ihr ja auch jemand anderen herausfordern
zum Spätzle-Schab-Contest.
Dann schreibt es auch gerne.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde, du hast dich echt supergut angestellt.
>> SARAH: Danke. Ich habe mir...
>> SALLY: Kannst du jetzt noch mal was richtig Schwäbisches
sagen?
>> SARAH: Oi.
>> SALLY: Oi.
>> SARAH: Aber das kommt jetzt spontan.
Das habe ich vorhin schon rausgeballert.
>> SALLY: Ich kenne nur: Sell hammer halbe dacht.
>> SARAH: Ich kann kein Schwäbisch.
>> SALLY: Echt?
Und ich habe das all die Jahre nicht gewusst.
Ihr sagt immer, ich rede so schwäbisch.
Wenn ich heimgehe, meine Oma sagt immer:
"Du redest so hochdeutsch, Mädle.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> SARAH: Kannst du auch mal wieder
a weng Schwäbisch schwätzen?"
Dann sage ich immer: "Ah ja, Oma,
bald wieder."
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also,
>> SARAH: Sonst versteht mich keiner.
>> SALLY: ob schwäbisch oder badisch
oder was ganz anderes, egal,
Hauptsache, ihr macht die Spätzle mal nach.
>> SARAH: Oh, ich wollte gerade einen Reim bringen
und du hast nicht aufgehört zu reden.
>> SALLY: Ob schwäbisch oder badisch,
>> SARAH: ihr seid sympathisch.
>> SALLY: Tschau!
Symbadisch.
>> SARAH: Nee.
Nee!
>> SALLY: Doch.
>> SARAH: Nee, nee, nee. Symschwäbisch.
>> SALLY: Josh, sag es. Symbadisch.
>> SARAH: Symschwäbisch.
>> JOSH: Symbadisch.
>> SALLY: Symbadisch. >> SARAH: Symschwäbisch.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Läuft es schon?
>> SARAH: Warum hältst du mir das so hin,
als würdest du mir das ins Gesicht schlagen?
>> SALLY: Sarah, weißt du, was das bedeutet?
>> SARAH: Nee.
Mhm.
Was meinst du?
Boah! Kennst du das Äffle und Pferdle?
Ja!
O Gott! Sie sind aus dem Schwabenland, oder nicht?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Sonst hätte ich es nicht gesagt.
>> SALLY: Warte.
Okay.
>> SARAH: Die fragen sich nämlich
auch immer so dumme Fragen.
Also nicht dumm.
Nicht dumm.
>> SALLY: So wie wir zwei oder was?
>> SARAH: Nee, sorry.
Weißt du? Das "Ha noi!"
"Ha was?"
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte mal.
Dann spiel du den Esel.
Was war das?
Sorry.
>> SARAH: Ein Affe und ein Pferd!
[Musik]